all they had to do was give the babylon
b its account back
all the libs had to do
was just not censor every little tiny
thing that they disliked all the way
down to a satire website but they
couldn't do it
the libs who ran twitter just couldn't
do it
so elon musk had to take twitter away
from them
it is now official the company has
confirmed that elon musk is the owner of
twitter
it all went down exactly as he said it
would
in less than three weeks elon musk went
from announcing a major investment in
twitter to gobbling up the entire
company to take it private
at first the board tried to stop the
takeover by offering musk a board seat
that didn't work
then they tried to stop the takeover by
issuing a poison pill to water down his
shares and stop him from buying more
that didn't work then they leaned on
woke financial institutions blackrock
state street to block the takeover
that didn't work the kingdom of saudi
arabia even got in on the action trying
to stop musk from buying twitter
that didn't work
in the end elon musk bought twitter for
exactly the price that he offered from
the very start he got
exactly what he wanted and he didn't pay
one penny more than he offered
the move is
terrific for a lot of reasons for one
the libs are losing their minds they
have not cried this hard since election
night 2016 which is
delightful
also important censored conservatives
will likely get their voice back on
twitter
which is important because twitter is in
many ways the public square and speaking
in the public square is how republics
govern themselves a lot of conservatives
are reporting right now that their
follower accounts have exploded
overnight their engagement has exploded
overnight i've seen it myself i'm up
something like 25 000 followers in 24
hours
part of that might be the fire tweets
that i'm sending but i think maybe a
clearer explanation is technologically
algorithmically
something must have changed no less
important though than than both of those
reasons perhaps the most delightful part
of it all
elon musk is right now in real time
vindicating the great man theory of
history the idea that individual men can
actually shift to some degree
and set and reset the course of human
events
for years now the libs have wanted us to
believe that individuals cannot make a
difference that history is governed
simply merely by an impersonal science
quote unquote that that will unfold
regardless of what human beings actually
want or do
the arc of history inevitably bending
toward whatever the libs want
they were so confident
and then in walks some eccentric south
african billionaire possibly a
conservative i'm not even really sure
to take not only twitter
but their total absolute hegemony and
their confidence away from them
absolutely love it i'm so glad you liked
that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications head on over also to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
and type in
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]